welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and we finally have a trailer for
venom let there be carnage
there's a lot to be excited about this
movie from the fact that woody
harrelson's gonna be playing cletus
cassidy carnage to the fact that andy
circus is directing it
so i'm just gonna react to this trailer
go into my initial thoughts on what this
movie's gonna be
and then tomorrow i'll have a frame by
frame breakdown of all the details you
missed in this
sound good great let's do this let's get
excited to watch a serial killer
and here we go whoa
oh they like to do their trailer to the
trailer
thing
okay what
is it coming out of his ass
[Music]
i like how venom tucked them in don't
make too bad good evening eddie hey mrs
chen
good evening that's dan
i love how mrs chen knows and loves i
know
she's [ __ ] i mean thank you
every decision
[Music]
after yep rescuer who never comes
welcome back eddie brock
and fix the hair good
chaos
chaos
what
be what be what oh yeah okay got
delivery hasn't it yet
what's gonna happen you're gonna stop
protecting me
no no you cannot eat what
whoa cool gonna put some dirt in your
eye miss chen
okay let's talk about this design for
carnage i gotta say with the tendrils
looks very cool very comic accurate of
course
maddening that they light them from
behind because all you really see is the
rim light on this texture and they add
this
shaky cam effect so that like you know
it's hard it's easy to hide the detail
there but yeah from what i can tell each
tendril kind of has its
own shape its own personality its own
way to kill you
we have some that look like a mace some
that look like there's like
jagged blades coming out of each one
there's a bit of slime that drops down
from the one on the right
but so far from this it's still kind of
hard to tell what the carnage
personality is
like we get a good sense of who cletus
cassidy is which is great and we know
distinctly who eddie brock is and who
venom is which is great but carnage is
just more than an
alien monster he's supposed to have his
own kind of identity his
own extreme amplification of what cletus
cassidy thinks he's not just like an
alien death monster so in the way that
they use tom hardy's voice to do venom
i'm wondering if they'll do woody
harrelson
modulate his voice and make that the
carnage voice but ultimately that's a
big part of it it's not just the look
and the design
it's the really messed up things this
character as carnage is gonna say
and do so i'm really excited to see what
they come up with there
but before we continue thanks to honey
for sponsoring this video online
shopping has basically become the only
kind of shopping that's where today's
sponsor honey comes in
honey is the free browser extension that
scours the internet for coupon codes and
automatically test them
at checkout so here's how it works you
get honey on your computer for free and
two easy clicks and then when you're
checking out one of its 30 000 supported
sites
honey pops up and all you have to do is
click apply coupons you wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
for that site and if honey finds a
working code you will watch your prices
drop
like honey showed me a special deal for
60 off a greeting card from target.com
the person i was getting that grading
card for does not need to know i got
such a good deal
those of you who have already installed
honey using my link have found
over 50 thousand dollars in savings so
take it from me if you have a computer
honey should be on it i wouldn't
recommend something i don't actually use
so get honey for free by going to
joinhoney.com
new rockstars that's joinhoney.com new
rockstar so they know i
sent you and thanks again honey for
sponsoring this video i gotta say i
am enjoying the sick sense of humor that
this movie has similar to what reuben
fleischer was going to in the previous
movie what i am missing
is some nasty r-rated red band violence
i don't think you can really do carnage
without making him r-rated that's what
was cool about the comics is that he was
gross he was violent he was profane
and i know it's just like a teaser
trailer but as of now the grossest thing
carnage does is
like stay his own execution and um
whip it all out in church which i guess
that's that's pretty obscene but i gotta
say
so far this trailer makes this movie
look pretty steeped in marvel lore you
have that little nod to stan lee
you have the cop reading the daily bugle
newspaper about the victims of cletus
cassidy and we've talked about how in
other videos before this movie is using
the old daily bugle print logo from sam
raimi era films not the new infowars
dailybugle.net logo that jay jonah
jameson was using at the end apart from
home
though on the interface of that
newspaper it looks like that might be
the word avengers there so who knows
what universe is taking place and i'll
go into it more in tomorrow's breakdown
and of course the ravencroft institute
now remember the ravencroft institute
from the amazing spider-man 2
this is the prison for the criminally
insane and marvel world a lot of super
villains are experimented on here
in this case we're going to have cletus
cassidy and it looks like shriek that's
another spider-man villains movie played
by naomi harris you know her from the
bond movies in the pirate movies
uh so according to director andy circus
this movie is gonna be in
its own world like these characters
don't know spider-man exists which i
would respond
how that character is now officially a
globe-trotting celebrity
like san francisco isn't in a bubble
carl the fog isn't that thick
they know what's going on with the rest
of the world or maybe that just tells us
this movie's set
maybe a bit before peter parker emerges
on the scene or just
likely not really connected to the mcu
that much it's just sony's never really
given us a clear answer on that because
i think legally they can't give us that
clear of an answer of how well these
characters are aware of tom holland
peter parker
and as with the first film the hard
thing about that is these characters are
in many ways defined by their
relationship to spider-man now yes
carnage is a derivative of venom and
they do have their own
antagonism and rivalry between the two
but what's fun about carnage is he's so
sick so messed up that
venom a previous villain has to team up
with spider-man to defeat him but right
now with this movie sony seems to be
trying to carve out a world where
spider-man isn't needed but
even in our world we need spider-man
right but from what i can gather from
the plot it looks like the post-credits
scene to the end of the first film saw
eddie brock doing these interviews with
cletus cassidy the deranged serial
killer and that cletus sees something in
eddie i had assumed he saw that kind of
split personality with the venom
symbiote and he was able to kind of
detect that in him
and as someone who's probably got some
mental issues on his own was able to
relate with that kind of uh
dissociative identity disorder i don't
think that's what he has here i'm just
saying that he could see that there's
something broken or damaged inside him
and now eddie brock the journalist is
the only person
cletus cassidy will give interviews too
but somehow in that relationship cletus
is gonna get a piece of the symbiote in
him maybe eddie will
bleed on his way out of san quentin and
then the blood will just kind of like
inchworm over to woody harrelson and
allow him to
jesus stay this execution with the red
working its way back up the tube there
the poor victims family just watching i
mean haven't they gone through enough
yeah a lot of stuff in here i want to
break down the
little details of but this last shot in
front of the church stained glass now
this is interesting the past i've
speculated that
this movie could be adapting loosely the
events of absolute carnage which
goes into the cult of null null is the
symbiote deity and in absolute carnage
he kind of creates this
cult of mind-controlled carnage drones
by getting in the minds of san
francisco's homeless community
it's a really really messed up storyline
it sounds like circus doesn't want to
give too much away about what's going on
specifically
in this scene in the church so i'm
wondering if that's a big direction
they're going to be going in
okay those are my initial thoughts as i
said there's a lot of little details in
this trailer which i'm grateful for that
i'm going to be breaking down frame by
frame in a breakdown coming out tomorrow
so
stay tuned for that you can support this
channel by checking out a great merch
options at directorsmerch.com follow me
at eavos on instagram and twitter follow
new rockstars and subscribe here on
youtube for breakdowns of everything you
love
thanks for watching
[Music]
you